it's a trend called girl math there are
a bunch of videos explaining this
concept uh here's one that I think lays
it out pretty clearly watching so for
example if you spend $100 and you get a
$10 reward you just made
$10 that's that's that's that's not
accurate that's that's not how that
works yeah because now in a future
purchase you just saved yourself $10 if
you return an item at the store you just
earn money so if you return something
and buy something at the same time
it was free no no no you cuz you had to
spend the money the first time no but
then the second time it's free cuz it's
no extra money or like if you pay for
cash with something it's free because
it's not coming out of your bank account
right so that's girl math and as you can
see as you already expected girl math is
just bad math it's not math it's anti-th